so about four months ago I posted a
video on this YouTube channel which was
a letter to myself ten years ago which
was actually a pretty Frank admission
that my mental health was bad I was reek
and I had been for some time now the
response to that video was phenomenal
people were so wonderfully kind and I
felt I was so incredibly lucky to have
this community that has built up around
these videos so I just want to say
formally thank you so much for being so
nice in the four odd months since I made
that video
I basically stepped away from my job so
I wasn't making YouTube videos I was
focusing entirely on myself and really
rebooting me I'm come Simon 2.0 right
now and so I wanted to make this video
to talk about what I was doing in that
time and how I've got back to the
position I'm in now because I'm a very I
feel like a very different person than
the person I was in that video and I
hope that this will be helpful to others
because something that I got from the
response to that first video was that it
was helpful to people instructive to
people who were in a similar situation
and maybe were being honest with
themselves so I'm making this video
because I hope that talking about what I
did how I did it will be instructive to
people who are maybe going on a similar
kind of journey in my video identified
three principal problems which were a
lack of confidence anxiety and
depression now just by making the video
I made myself significantly less anxious
it felt like a giant weight had been
lifted off my shoulders when I felt like
my I wasn't hiding something from my
community when I have for so long so
just making the video was cathartic and
what followed immediately after that as
I said was stepping back from YouTube
before basically I hope originally was
only gonna do a week and I was talking
to Sally my friend Sally LePage about
how I was gonna take a week off and she
was like no no this this is gonna be
like a multi-month thing and you know
she has this annoying habit of being
right sometimes I basically took the
rest of that year off from the end of
October till the end of the year just
focusing on myself and that allowed me
to you know combat the feelings that I
had about to being depressed and being
sad and being stressed the whole time
and allowed me to focus on spending time
with my partner with pixel go with my
family over Christmas and also just
doing things which I enjoy I've watched
a lot of Star Trek The Next Generation
I've also been painting Warhammer and
pixel ago and I made a big scary couples
decision and we bought a piano together
and so we've been learning to play that
and just actually doing stuff which I
enjoy and it felt like it'd been so long
since I'd invested time in myself in
that way so that initial period of sort
of investing time in myself
was super important the single scariest
thing I did in this whole period was
actually going to a medical professional
so I never talked to any medical
professional about my mental health
before and going to the doctor's going
to a GP and basically laying it all out
there was very intimidating but I am so
incredibly glad that I did so at the
moment I am in a waiting list for
cognitive behavioral therapy on the NHS
and I have been taking antidepressant
and anti-anxiety medication for several
months and that has been absolutely
wonderful something I should stress is
that the medication isn't a cure it's
like a band-aid it's a sticking-plaster
for the symptoms what it allows me to do
though is actually be able to get back
to work which is why in the the new year
I've been able to start making videos
again because I don't feel their
symptoms quite as keenly I've actually
been able to sleep properly for the
first time in what feels like years so
in general the medication and going to
the NHS has allowed me to function again
that was one of the crucial things which
I did in that whole period something
else which I did in this period was get
back into exercise in a really sort of
regular way I kind of fell off the
fitness bandwagon after I did my two
half marathons last year and a lot of
that was basically because I was tired
the whole time and I was also anxious
all the time so I just never wanted to
go into exercise and that meant that I
gained a lot of weight because I was
comfort eating and since December I have
really been poking that to rights
so people who follow me on Instagram
will know this because I put it on my
stories all the time but I'm going to
the gym every week I've been losing a
lot of weight I am the best part of ten
kilos down from the start of the year so
incredibly happy with the progress on
that and that's done a lot to restore my
self-confidence
just generally make me feel better about
myself however the single biggest change
that I've made and has improved my
mental health so much has been how I've
organized my life and I mean both my
personal life and my work life and the
person has made that possible has been
pixel go I owe such a debt of gratitude
to pixel go for everything she's done in
this period she has been so supportive
and patient and I I love her so much for
it and something specific that she got
me to do was to start using the software
which she's been using in her master's
work so she's doing a master's in
education at the moment and she
organizes all of her notes in this bit
of software called notion now she got
into notion via a youtuber called Ali
Abdullah who some of you may be aware of
he has a channel we talked about
productivity and organization and I went
to meet him quite recently and I got him
to explain what notion is and how he
uses it so you you describe it as your
life OS so you basically do everything
in it right I do a lot of things in it
yeah III use it to kind of organize my
kind of daily productivity I use it as
an address book to an extent I used to
track my gym work house manage my
youtube videos to kind of do team stuff
with the people that I'm working with I
also use it for like my medical school
notes and for preparing for super
visions that I'm teaching and from
writing questions and for even keeping
track of what friends are doing when I
when I have hangouts Hangouts with
friends I don't like write a few notes
about it in notion so use a notion for
so much stuff I mean honestly you
introducing it to me has completely
revolutionized the way that I do my job
has changed how organized I am i get to
completely turn my life around so
honestly thank you so much you're very
welcome unable to make that video thank
you seriously game-changing it has I
think been the single most impactful
change that I've made in these past four
months I cannot overstate how much of a
difference it has made to how I feel how
my mental health has been so I think the
best thing that I can do at this point
is literally just show you how I've been
using notion because it's so flexible
that's all about the specific
implementation that you do and this
implementation I think has been one of
the principal reasons I've been able to
get back to work and I feel so much more
on top of things now as I said at the
start of the video too
the major problems that I talked about
in that previous video were a lack of
self confidence and a general anxiety I
think both of them tied up at this
problem I had of just feeling like I was
stumbling through life I didn't really
have a clear direction I didn't have
goals that I was striving towards so one
of the principal things that I've been
able to do with notion is put together a
set of goals for the year and then break
them down into what I want to accomplish
every month some of this is going to be
censured by the way because some of its
very personal and some of it is to do
with projects I can't talk about yet
it's exciting so for example here in
March I'm gonna be doing some tests for
a new warhammer army that I'm gonna be
painting several eye for color schemes
and stuff I've got the books that I want
to read and I've also got my this video
that I'm gonna make as well as some
goals for fitness and some stuff which I
can't show you now those goals will have
come from something which is done higher
up in the page which is what are my
objectives for this year and some of
those objectives are be healthy go on
holiday to Madrid which we're going to
be doing the following month so we
organized actually ahead of schedule and
then some of them I actually haven't
stated in here I might actually add
right now read 30 books I read 25 books
last year and I want to try and do five
better this year now this is all well
and good but it's all on a monthly basis
whereas I have found that the most
productive way of using it has been
doing weekly to-do lists and the way
that I've done that is have a template
here where I can add a new week and this
page has got to-do lists all rigged up
for the different days of the week along
with a weekly reflection and prep the
next week every Sunday so something that
I definitely have hit on is that regular
reflection and regular planning has been
crucial to assess how well I'm doing
because then that helps with the self
confidence it shows that actually you
know you are accomplishing stuff you're
reaching towards these longer-term goals
on like a monthly and yearly basis and
it's - all the small steps which you
reflect on at the end of the week you
realize add up and then knowing what
you're doing next week helps with the
anxiety of not feeling like you're going
anywhere in life it's it's literally
tackling the two biggest problems I've
been suffering from head-on now all that
stuff's my personal life but I also have
this page for my youtube channel I also
have pages
for the big project that I can't talk
about for the wiki cast my podcast and
for the finances of like everything I do
all together and what's really been
useful here has been video projects so
this is all the stuff that's going to be
coming out in the next couple of months
I've got stuff planned until August and
then a whole raft of ideas which I'm not
going to show you because I'm worried
about being sniped by the science
achievers but what you can see here is
the stuff that's gonna be coming out
including this video and I'll give you a
teaser of the one that's gonna come out
next because I'm a I'm generous I guess
but this is a database so I can just
change the view that we're looking at so
if I put this to complete it for example
then let's look at the team trees page
so this is a page within the database it
has the script in here it has the bullet
point form which I start out with the
script and then I can also put stuff
like has this been added to never below
the streaming service line part of have
I been paid for it if it was a sponsored
video and it just means that I have
everything to do with the video all in
one place so I have been recently
working with outsourcing some work to
some video editors from the community
which has been a huge relief and it has
allowed me to make more regular content
than I would otherwise be able to do I
can send them a link to this page and it
has everything in one place so for
example the video which I did on the its
first effect I sent this to my editor
Anna and there's a color coded scheme
here so I could say these are the bits
which I wants to be just me on camera
the bits that I want voiceover and the
bits which need graphics she didn't do
those graphics I did them but it
honestly sped up the process so much
something that you might have noticed by
the way is that it's very personalizable
so I have like custom icons for the
different videos I have a custom
background and basically all these pages
it's a simple thing but making it like a
nice environment has made such a
difference to me actually using the
software before I was using a hodgepodge
mix of todoist which I still use for
some regular tasks Google Doc Google
Calendar you know all this work stuff
was spread out all over the place and it
just wasn't a terribly nice experience
to use stuff fell through the cracks
where this it's all in one place and I
can actually make it looking like
I can make it nice to look at it's silly
but having this stuff like making
actually look nice I don't know it makes
me more likely to use it which means
that I am more likely to be productive
and drawing on something that are
leaders I have done a year-end review
I'm gonna do one at the end of this year
I actually do small reviews at the end
of the month as well which just allow
for again it's helping with that
self-confidence and it's been really
useful in making me aware of how close I
am or how far away I am for achieving
particular goals it also shows that if
you use the service then you can
actually use pages which have been
templated by somebody else so this was a
page that Hallie made and I just
modified and put my own data in the
YouTube database I sort of my videos I
basically took from Thomas Frank's video
on the same subject and you know it's
been super easy to just grab a template
and go yeah I'm going to use that done
now when I was putting together the
bullet points for this video and you
know what I wanted to talk about I
realized that I'd been talking about
notion a lot with you know whilst I was
writing it into notion and then that
same day I got an email from my agency
saying by the way have you heard of this
product called notion they want to
sponsor a video with you so in the most
unbelievable case of good luck I think
I've ever known this video is actually
sponsored by notion and if you want to
try it out the software if you like what
you've seen then you can do so
completely for free so the free version
of notion that anybody can sign up to
your limited to I think it's a thousand
blocks or like a thousand kind of
individual elements like lines of text
here in notion but if you upgrades to
the personal plan which is what I've got
here then you are unlimited you can put
as much information into it as you want
however if you are a student or an
educator of some kind like if you have
an academic email then you can actually
upgrade to this personal plan completely
for free motion introduced that like
late last year as I hope I've
communicated to you by this point in the
video this has been absolutely
game-changing for me I don't think it
will be an exaggeration to say that
notion has been the single thing that
has allowed me to turn my life around in
the past couple of months
I mean yet that's not to discount the
support that I've got from my family and
from picks or girl and all the work that
I've put in
selves but it's the organization it's
feeling like I'm on top of my stuff and
I know where I'm going that has made me
feel less anxious it's made me feel a
lot more confident in myself and it's
definitely allowed me to get back to
work sooner than I otherwise would have
done so if you're watching this and you
think you would benefit from that kind
of organization and that could be a bit
particularly if you're a student but
that could be for your work life it
could be for personal life or like me a
mix of the two I cannot recommend it
it's it's honestly been fantastic for me
thank you for watching the video I
really hope that you took something away
from this if you found yourself in a
situation similar to what I was going
through a couple of months ago I really
hope that you have some actionable items
from this you can learn from my
experiences because no matter how bleak
it seems you can always turn things
around that's I think probably the
single biggest thing I've learned in the
past couple of months thank you again
for watching and I will see you in the
next video
[Music]